- Have you ever run into
any like celebrity crushes?
Any of your--
- Yes.
- Yes
- I wrote about one in my book.
So, I had a crush on Michael Fassbender.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you had one, so it's over?
- It's kind of over in that he's married
and it's rude, to be like
(crowd laughing)
"I'm trying to hit that."
(Kelly laughs)
But, when I met him, I was
newly familiar with him,
but I didn't realize it
was him when I met him.
Because he was sitting,
I was behind, and so he
was talking to me this way,
so I didn't really get
a full look at his face
and had this whole conversation,
he was super, super charming.
And then when I left, I was
walking out and I was like,
(groans)
I think that was Fassbender.
(crowd laughing)
'Cause he just said, "Michael,"
you know, he just
introduced himself Michael.
And my friend who was with me,
I was like, "He was so
nice, he was kinda flirty."
She goes, "You know he likes black girls."
and I was like "whoa."
(crowd laughing)
(Kelly claps)
Damn, I just played myself.
It didn't dawn on me until
it was already too late,
and then I was mad because
on "Parks and Rec",
my character names her car,
after Micheal Fassbender,
'cause it's a Mercedes, she
names it Micheal Fassbender
because, it's German and it's sexy.
- You had all the time--
- And so, I have all
the ammunition to be like
"so what you doing later?"
(crowd laughing)
German sexy, and I just played myself
and then like a year later,
I saw him at the Golden Globes.
Don't worry about it, it's not a big deal,
I go where he goes.
(Kelly laughs)
- And,
so were at the Golden Globes
and my publicist Taige,
he was like "two people
down from me on the carpet,"
and I literally was like, (gasps)
and she was like, "What's wrong with you?"
And I was like, "That's
Fassbender, it's Fassbender."
And she was like, "You
want me to introduce you?"
I was like, "I will kill
you where you stand."
If you say something.
- I am the same way.
- I get so embarrassed, yeah.
- But you know--
- Unless I embarrass myself.
- Right, but then,
- Yeah.
- It's the Globes, so
it's a lot of cocktails.
- Yeah, not for me I got terrified,
I was like I am not drinking.
- Oh, really?
- I already make a fool
of myself sober, yeah.
- They had already taken
all the food off the table,
so it was just liquor
and breadsticks.
- They want you to get drunk.
- So, I was drinking,
- They want you--
- Champagne all night,
and there was a point where he walked up.
And we were sitting not
far from the bathroom,
so everybody who had
to go to the bathroom,
had to pass our table, and there was,
I don't really remember this.
I found this out afterwards
because I had a lot of drinks.
But my EP had said to us,
"Yeah Retta, you don't
remember Michael Fassbender?
I was like, "No!"
He is like, "He walked up to the table,
he smiled at you," (laughs)
instead of responding
you just leaned back and said,
"You know I like black girls."
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd laughs)
(screams) Awesome.
- Oh my God, I love your person.
There, I love your, he will be missed out.
- I did.
- You played yourself twice.
- Yeah, I played myself twice.
- You just really
did not want him inside your body I think.
- I mean, I guess--
- Well, congratulations, oh oh oh!
No no no no no no no no no no.
(audience laughs)
No, that is no! (laughs)
- Oh my God! (laughs)
I like that, there was a riffle of.
(mocking)
- That is not what I meant.
I mean like deep inside
some of your subconscious.